the jurgen experience and so
to be like working with him and sit he's
sitting there i'm like i've seen you on
tv
by the way i seen you in the morning
great was phil he was amazing he was
i had my scariest one of my scariest
professional moments involved phil
hartman
i was uh i was hosting the show on
saturday
live and phil and i fill out a character
called
mace that he did reoccurring character
and mace was a hard-bitten convict and
he lived in it obviously he was serving
life and
uh you know so whenever they had like
you know pretty boy hosts
they would throw of course me into a
cell with may say
turn around their chicken legs you know
so that was that was like the predicate
of the
and and i just remember apropos of
nothing it was the week that the lambada
dance was a big deal oh jesus that tells
you how long it was
yeah so so mace and i were doing the
lambada and a prison cell
and the whole sketch built towards
um a a uh a punch line
and for whatever reason i blew the setup
line
like like blue blue it like there's no
there's now no end there oh look there
we go
look at him hey look at you chicken legs
um and so there was no so i had to
ad-lib
something really really really really
quickly it felt like time stretched out
and his eyes got huge and i
i ad-lib libbed something and it worked
and it got a really big laugh and i
think that
um that's when what sort of sealed my
relationship with lauren michaels
because i was able to
he came back backstage and was like um
you're really houdini aren't you
that's gotta be terrifying to do that
show to do it live
it's the best oh if i could if i could
have been a
not ready for primetime player i would
have i mean that would have been the
journey i think that's the dream how
much preparation
do you have to do for that show like how
many times do you rehearse one of those
sketches
well being what people don't really
realize about being a host is it's
the host show like you can take as much
control over it as you want and most
people don't
um i i just being stupid and naive did
and always did and
sat in on the writers all night write
all night with all the different writers
going from room to room it was
[ __ ] heaven but i was an snl nerd so
it was like um that's cool and then and
then you do the
the dress rehearsal of course right
before air
and it's a full show it's exactly the
same show full audience it's the whole
thing and then they cut things or not
one of my favorite things that got cut
and
will ferrell and i played um
oncologists who would
deliver the bad news that people had
stage four cancer but only with our
mouths full of food
so be like that was that was it was yeah
he'd be like
oh yeah i'm sorry i'm eating chili whoa
whoo this is hot spreading the root of
my mouth sorry so sorry
um you have stage four cancer oh wow so
hot and spicy that was the
that was the total predicate of of the
sketch that was
weird it was like so weird and so i it
made it to
to air it means dress wow really crazy
it must been a rough week it's a rough
week i don't think cancer's funny
yeah i guess you got a point there phil
hated uh
the competitive aspect of the show
because he said that
people were just mean to each other
that's one of the things that he enjoyed
about sitcoms is that everybody was kind
of working together
he said one of the things about when you
do snl everyone's
battling to get their sketch on yeah so
they would sort of sabotage each other
and they would kind of there was a lot
of like backstabbing [ __ ] going on and
he didn't like it and he was really
hesitant
like to be friendly with people on the
set like when he first
got on the sitcom it took a while for
him to loosen up
and realizes oh this is a different
thing because that that environment
was every man for himself yeah it's it's
funny
ensembles are are funny that way like
there is a an element of teamwork it's
like any team there's an element of
teamwork that's intrinsic and you want
and is great and hopefully it's there
but then there's that that element of of
you know competitiveness even with your
sort of band of brothers but
you know that that gets toxic in a hurry
with the right with
with the wrong culture and and maybe the
wrong
people in it but but snl it's like it is
what it is there's only so many slots
for sketches
and there are only so many people
writing and the best is when people try
to tank them in the read through
like you read all of them on wednesday a
big huge stack of them
and people will like laugh really really
hard at their own stuff or like
roll their eyes it's it's fun to watch
yeah that's basically what he's talking
about that that always
made me really uncomfortable the fake
producer laugh
like when you'd be doing like the third
run through and like
like ugh you're dead ugh but people
don't even know what we're talking about
so like
when you do a table read we've done the
most unrelatable podcast
ever just now it's been great famous and
young and good-looking oh and um
and doomsday prepping and uh
earthroamers
yes this is great you know there's
there's nobody quite like a man of the
people joe rogan and roblox podcast
let's face it